and here's the code that we use to do
that now you might remember formatted
name from before and we added formatted
role now to create our formatted role
we took HTML header role dot replace and
we replace the data placeholder with the
role that we created up here so this
next bit of code is a little bit tricky
so over here we have our header div we
can see that header already has an
unordered list inside of it so if we pin
the data it would actually put the data
right here we want it to show at the
beginning of our header tag right here
in order to add elements to the
beginning we actually need to use
prepend instead of append so we want our
name to appear first in our role to
appear second so running through this
code when we append our format it role
it will show up at the top here and then
when we prepend our name instead of
showing it at the end as append wood it
will insert it in the beginning